welcome everyone to lawn crime daily I'm
Brian buckmeyer day two of rapper ynw
melly's murder trial in South Florida
brought long periods of testimony from
crime scene investigators the
prosecution wants to show the jury why
they believe Mellie was the shooter
inside an SUV back in October of 2018.
Melly whose given name is Jamel demons
is accused of killing two men he called
his friends in October of 2018 mellie's
best friend Cortland Henry showed up out
of Miami Hospital claiming his friends
were caught in a drive-by shooting and
were bleeding out in the car Anthony
Williams and Christopher Thomas had
multiple gunshot wounds and were
pronounced dead Henry told officers they
were shot at a shot at while leaving a
recording studio but when police got
there they said there was no evidence
that a drive-by had occurred
investigators determined to the victims
were shot by someone in the car and
surveillance show four men inside
including Melly police arrested Mellie
and Henry on two counts of first-degree
murder each they are being tried
separately and have both pled not guilty
the prosecutor walked one investigator
through the photos he took of the Jeep
where Thomas and Williams were killed we
want to warn you some of the photos do
show blood inside the SUV
that is the area between the front
passenger seat and the door jamb for the
front passenger door okay
next photo what are we looking at here
the front passenger side floorboard
moving on here the seats did you
manipulate them in any way before taking
this photograph
moving on into the next photograph what
are we looking at there
those are gold Casper teeth
and so it's clear that that's a close-up
photo
from this rear passenger door is that a
correct statement yes I swear
what are we looking at in this photo
that is
so I'm going to go back a photo
is that the same projectile that is down
here yes it is going forward again what
are we looking at in this image
that is the rear pass side forward and
items that were found out there
continuing to the next photo what are
you documenting in this image
in this image you can see the partial
back of the front passenger side seat
the again floorboard of the rear
passenger side forward
the rear passenger side seat
and a projectile hole that you can see
and so I'm going to zoom in on an area
can you explain what you're talking
about the projectile hole yes can you
connect the screen to touch if you're to
draw attention to certain areas I
observed the defect in the seat
that is that you've gone into detail
okay
whether you got documenting in this
image
this image shows the trunk which had
been opened and in the photograph you
can see
car manual and a jacket
did you disturb any of the glass did any
of the glass move when you were opening
that trunk not that I recall
all right let's bring in my co-host
former trial Attorney Terry Austin and
our very special guest former homicide
prosecutor Bernardo villalona Terry a
lot of today's assassinate may have
seemed really dry not just to some of
our viewers but probably some of us as
well but why is it necessary to go
through each and every piece of evidence
in so much detail well
because Federal Rules of Evidence you
have to make sure that obviously it's
relevant in all these photos with this
particular witness were relevant but you
have to lay a foundation to authenticate
each and every photo and in order to do
that you have to ask the individual did
you take the picture is this a fair
representation is it an accurate
representation of the scene at the time
if all of that goes well then it can be
introduced but the process itself is
also tedious because you have to first
ID the piece of evidence and then you
have to show it to opposing counsel and
then you have to show it to the witness
and then you lay that foundation and
then the judge you may get an objection
in The Duchess to rule then you have it
into evidence and it's published so it's
a process yeah those are the same rules
that the states have I always tell
people hey the foundation of a home
isn't sexy but if it's cracked you're
not going to want to buy that home it's
probably the same thing here Bernardo
some of the photos of the crime scene
showed a graphic photo or footage sorry
of the car containing blood stains there
was an objection by defense at one point
do you think photos could be prejudicial
to the jury
oh you have to think with these
photographs the judge had to weigh its
probative effect versus its probative
value versus its prejudicial effect of
course it's prejudicial in the sense
that it leads to the guilt of the
defendant however it's relevant to the
sense that the prosecutor had to lay out
what did the crime scene look like and
also where the pieces of evidence were
located especially in the case where the
defendant claimed that their the
injuries occurred as a result of being
shot at this will tend to dispute the
car being as a result of a drive-by but
instead of that the shooting took place
inside so of course the probative value
definitely outweighs the prejudicial
effect yeah it gives us a lot more
information about what happened in that
car well lawn crime has a reporter Bryce
and Paul inside the courtroom covering
this trial for us he's able to give us
some insight into what the cameras don't
see let's take a listen
you definitely noticed the animosity
between the victims family and Y W
melly's family both have Let's cross
back and forth at each other on multiple
occasions
um as evidence and video shows of the
now deceased victims you can see the
victims families even look directly at
Melly with the same look on their face
uh just you can see when they have the
videos of Melly and and there are Millie
and his group of friends walking around
even leading up to the murder you'll see
Melody's Mom look over at the at the
victim's family to see what their
reactions are and even at one point in
time
when we were about to break uh
the victim winw juve's mother even got
up in the middle of the gallery and
stared directly at y w Melly until he
looked at her he's definitely not
looking forward to looking at the
deceased he actually refuses every time
whether they're alive in the video or
not he refuses to look in the air at
them in the video he actually just turns
away either turns down his head or uh
consorts with his counsel
we're finishing Today's Show in Green
Bay Wisconsin Taylor's your business
appeared in court for a motion hearing
as a judge weighs whether she's
competent to stand trial on murder
charges should business is pleading Not
Guilty by reason of insanity to the
gruesome death of 24 year old Shad
Therian last year the defendant
allegedly confessed to investigators
that she choked him with a metal chain
during sex molested his course and
dismembered his body the victim's
remains were found scattered throughout
his mother's home and in the defendant's
van Tuesday's hearing address defense
motions to suppress certain evidence in
the case more specifically her
confession to police the defense believe
believes that Miranda rights weren't
given before some of the statements and
that she was also reportedly under the
influence of drugs therefore it could
not have been a voluntary confession one
witness who testified during the hearing
was an offense pharmacologist expert he
evaluated the defendant earlier this
month and described what she said about
drug use on the night of the murder
Taylor that would shed
there was drug use methamphetamine use
Shad was smoking methamphetamine
Taylor was
using intravenous methamphetamine which
were which was her usual method of
administration but that evening she also
smoked methamphetamine
there was a reference to
Shad being injected with trazodone
may or may not have been a reference to
Taylor
injecting herself with methane with
trazodone
um
there was an alleged
asphyxiation
she had died there's an alleged
dismemberment
um
a day later approximately a day later
the
sheds dismembered body was discovered in
his mother's basement
and shortly thereafter several or
several hours after that
um
police found Taylor
detained and arrested Taylor and
subsequently
interrogated her questioned her
and she was detained to the Brown County
jail so I took a history a thorough
history of her drug use both chronically
and up to the incident
so yes and she did admit to using
uh principally methamphetamine uh
practically daily if not daily
Bernardo the defense was that statement
by she business that she made to the
police to be suppressed for fair to get
Miranda warrants we know them yeah the
rights remain silent anything you say
Canon will be used against you but also
I'm kind of curious about this uh
intoxication argument what is the
likelihood of the the success of these
arguments
exactly Brian so if a judge is to find
that she wasn't able to knowingly or
voluntarily waive Her Miranda warnings
her right to remain silent then the
judge has no choice but to suppress the
statements so in terms of her
intoxication it plays a huge role in
determining whether she was able to
knowingly waive her right against giving
any statements so a judge is going to
take that into account because if you
are so intoxicated or under the
influence of whether narcotics or under
the influence of alcohol then your mind
supposedly cannot process or understand
what is being told to you and you can't
fully process and acknowledge that
you're normally waving your right
against giving a state more against
self-incrimination and if that is the
case the judge has no choice but to
suppress the statements but also she'll
get a second bite at the Apple at 12
because that same type of jury
instruction will be given to the jury to
make that determination yeah if it comes
in she'll be able to argue hey I was so
high I was so intoxicated you can't
believe anything I've been say it could
be a possibly good argument Terry the
attorney for your business requested a
second competency hearing the judge
previously denied the request but could
that request be reviewed it could be
reviewed and it could be renewed and I
think it should be I think defense
counsel really has a good argument here
she was originally looked at way back in
November and the judge made his decision
in March and what the defense is arguing
is look so much has happened between
November and March and now so he should
renew that she is I think having some
mental issues the fact that she attacked
her attorney that's one incident that
should be considered and I think even if
you don't use it for competency it could
be used as far as her mental illness at
trial yeah you cannot participate in
your defense finding your attorney could
be one of it Bernard Terry thank you and
thank you for joining us here on Law and
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss Justice in America
foreign